الى ماذا تؤشر الاجراءات الامنيه التي
اتخذها قاده الانقلاب بعد انتهاء مهله
اكوانس
[موسيقى]
المجال الجوي نعم
انقلابيين اين ضباط عسكريين
عن الضواحي والمحافظات وهذا كله لا يدل
على انه مستعد لاي حلول وسط
فرنسا هذا اول شيء يعني وهذا الذي كل من
النيجريين ينتظره حيث اتجهت الدوله مالي
وكذلك حيث اتجهت الدوله بوركينا فاذا هم
ايضا سوف يتجهون هذا يعني الاتجاه تشير
معلومات متطابقه بحوزتنا الى ان قوى
اجنبيه تعد لمهاجمه النيجر وشعبه بالتنسيق
مع منظمه ايكواس ومجموعات ارهابيه مسلحه
هل تعتقد ان الخيار العسكري لا يزال
مطروحا على طاوله لاكواس
سلطات الاكواس قدمت انذارا قبل اسبوع
وانتهى بالامس ولكن ذلك لا يعني بالضروره
ان اكوا ستقوم بغزو او اطلاق هجوم للتدخل
العسكري الحزب الحاكم اول موقفه على هذه
الضغوطات واغلاق الحدود والضغط الغربي
اتخذتها فرصه
لعوده النظام الشرعي للبلا التدخل العسكري
قد ياخذ وقتا طويلا
السلطه كانت متسرعه قليلا فيك وهسه باعلان
عقوبات
وفي الوقت ذاته اصدرت انذارا
وضعت خط احمر على الطاوله لم افتحوا مجالا
للوساطه او الحوار
وفقط اللاج الى خيار القوه كخيار الاول
واعتقد ان هذا سيخلق مشاكل كثيره ما هي
الحلول غير العسكريه التي يمكن ان يطرحها
اكواس لعوده الديمقراطيه لابد للعوده الى
الديمقراطيه لابد للاودها ولكن للاسف
الوقت الرائن الان
الهيئه العسكريه او السلطه العسكريه لابد
ان يدرسوا الواقعه وكذلك ينظر رئيس ما
يعني اذا تم الامور اذا استقرت الامور لا
بد لهم يعني ان يقدموا او ان يعودوا الى
النظام يعني الديمقراطي كل الخيارات قد
تكون محدوده
الصغينا بحرص لما قاله ال الوزير بلينكل
فانه تحدث
ولم يبدعوا الى اعاده محمد بازون لم يدعوا
لعادته الى السلطه
بل دعا الى استعاده الديمقراطيه هذا
يتناقض بشكل كبير مع موقف
التي تصر على ان ضروره عوده بازوم الى
منصبه